-Guys, here's the thing.
I wrote a kid's book.
It's a picture book.
It's not a joke.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, yesterday I said
I wrote a kid's book,
and I held it up,
and everybody laughed
like it was gonna be
the start of some funny bit.
So that's why
I'm bracing you now.
I wrote a real book.
Did I do the pictures?
No.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it's for kids.
It is for kids,
if you have kids.
My kids like it,
which is great.
My publisher keeps telling me,
which is so exciting,
it is the first
kids book ever --
There have been books
with a bear or a rabbit.
It's the first one with both.
[ Laughter ]
Name one, Shoemaker!
Name one.
What? Okay, you don't
have a minute, you're out.